today we are doing a pancake competition
never done any kind of baking
competition with each other so we've
decided we're gonna try to make each
other's faces we are going to be
competing on who can make the tastiest
most creative pancake and when we're
done we're going to send a picture to a
friend or two we're gonna text our
friend Kristin see which pancakes she
likes better to make it a little more
spicy or weight or something if I win
she's gonna love my TV beats I win I
want a full body with thighs this is a
good game when you're tired of getting
along with the person okay so here we
are we have all of our ingredients here
we have fruit blueberries strawberries
bananas chocolate syrup for my chocolate
baby it's good to make sure that your
man is comfortable with the fact that
you're better at things than he is you
can calm down on your drink I am feeling
so free right now don't be looking
they're picking don't look is she
looking you'll know if she's looking
don't let her look spice up my pancake
Oh was the final touch of needed I mean
if I'm a senior citizen he's doing great
this is Mickey Mouse's cousin Moe Mouse
I'm almost in I just have one finishing
touch I'm ready to show me what you got
for turn and receives you're a pancake
why are you excited about that and
disgusting you make a dick I'm gonna
make a bigger difference I'm finished
this is what do you well this is a woman
you see this is this is a movie star
this is Charlize Theron he's done big
glasses you little ears yes should see a
doctor if we have like a UTI oh you guys
get you tears yeah Oh
our friends are good it's definitely
like this better well
so I'm taking pictures I'm sending this
to our friend Kristen and she is going
to judge and let us know who's the
winner so the friend doesn't know who
did which one I said which one do you
like better photo one or photo - we
haven't heard back from these the shot
sound smell it yeah I responded he is
the first response I want to say I want
to say the top one but them titties is
nice gonna say Tommy just got back to me
the first one is my big mark I was the
first one kiss please sign okay well
lisa has voted and she thinks that this
pancake makes Tom use her appetizer at
the super fun game it's a way to bond
yeah well I'm out 20 bucks you know in
the end I'm just going to enjoy eating
after his pancake cuz it looks delicious
I think it really we're both winners Oh
body massage we're ready to tell massage
enjoy the pancakes guys you might eat
dick Sunday Funday sure Cheers
it's okay babe you got syrup on your
face